on va passer au débat de ce club débat
sur la châssis la mission d'information
sur la sécurité de la chasse a rendu son
rapport il fait débat on va le voir avec
vous avant de commencer on va voir les
principaux chiffres un million de
Français sont des chasseurs le nombre
d'accidents de chasse puisque c'est de
ça dont il a été beaucoup question était
de 90 la saison passée contre 179 il y a
10 ans le nombre d'accidents mortels de
8 on va voir ce qu'il y a dans ce débat
puisque les sénateurs ont travaillé
justement sur cette question de la
chasse se sont emparés d'une pétition
qui a rassemblé Audrey plus de 120 000
signatures et qui réclamait plus de
sécurité autour de la chasse et son
interdiction au moins un jour par
semaine le rapport sénatorial vient donc
d'être rendu 30 propositions que
contient-il après 48 heures d'audition
cumulées 5 déplacements sur le terrain
et même des participations à débattu ça
y est les propositions sont tombées et
c'est non pour le jour sans chasse que
demander les créateurs de la pétition
les sénateurs estiment dans leur rapport
qu'il n'y a pas de
présentation des accidents les week-ends
et les mercredis ils laissent cela à la
discrétion des autorités locales
souvenez-vous pourtant l'interdiction de
la chasse un jour par semaine c'était
invité pendant la campagne
présidentielle Yannick Jadot et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l'avait même inscrite dans
leur programme alors à l'annonce de ces
propositions 9 associations anti-chats
sont dénoncées dans un communiqué un
rapport indécent qui rejette la
quasi-totalité de leur demande et elle
réclame un référendum sur l'instauration
du dimanche et du mercredi sans chasse
et puisqu'on en est aux réactions
écoutez celle de Daniel salmon sénateur
écologiste qui faisait partie de la
mission c'est un manque crucial ce qui
est ce qui est bien dommage parce que ça
allait dans le sens de l'apaisement nous
sommes dans une société fracturée on
attend des gestes on attend des gestes
forts et celui-là n'est pas là
il y a aussi une autre proposition de
ses collègues à laquelle il n'adhère pas
du tout qu'ils jugent même explosive le
rapport propose la création d'un délit
d'entrave à la chasse concrètement une
personne qui s'oppose à une action de
chasse pourrait s'exposer à une peine
d'un an d'emprisonnement et à 30000
euros et en ce qui concerne
l'encadrement de la chasse Audrey et
bien il y a des choses contre lesquelles
les chasseurs fulminent preuve pardon
s'il en fallait une que le sujet est
très sensible les sénateurs préconisent
une formation théorique et pratique pour
posséder une carabine un certificat
médical obligatoire à refaire tous les
ans l'interdiction de l'alcool et des
stupéfiants lors des parties de chasse
en s’alignant sur le code de la route
concrètement il s'agit de mettre les
mêmes règles pour la chasse que celle
qui existe déjà pour le tir sportif plus
anecdotique mais la formation pour être
responsable de battus pourraient devenir
obligatoire tout comme le PSC1
l'apprentissage des gestes de premiers
secours le président de la Fédération
Nationale des Chasseurs Willy Shrek a
dénoncé des propositions totalement
exagérées stigmat s'il a même complété
avec ironie il ne manque plus que la
proposition de phishés tous les
chasseurs voilà pour les points de ce
rapport on va revenir longuement
évidemment sur ce rapport durant ce
débat Patrick chaise vous en êtes
l'auteur vous êtes avec nous d'abord
Guillaume monta une réaction avant de
rentrer dans le détail comment avez-vous
réagi à la lecture de ce rapport et de
ses propositions
rapporteur de cette mission et quand
même me féliciter parce que c'est vrai
que ce moment est grâce à cette pétition
qui a recueilli effectivement vous
l'avez dit plus de 100 enfin 120 000
pétitionnaires et même encore le
compteur s'était arrêté donc on voit que
c'est un sujet particulièrement
important effectivement qui peut diviser
enfin qui divise notre notre société et
donc le fait qu'on se soit posé et qu'on
ait pu discuter pendant ces quelques
mois qui ont eu des auditions moi ça
c'est vrai que je m'en félicite et je et
je salue le travail même si
effectivement les conclusions les
orientations qui sont qui sont données
suite à ces différents échanges pour moi
ne vont pas dans le bon sens et parfois
sont provocateurs je pense qu'au
contraire je dirais que c'est peut-être
pour le coup une balle perdue en tout
cas un rapport qui n'atteint pas sa
cible parce que Daniel salmon disait je
pense qu'on aurait pu en profiter pour
apaiser les choses pour répondre quand
même à une demande profonde de la
société c'est vrai que cette pétition
elle est issue de quoi quand même de
cette demande d'un jour sans chasse et
encore un jour je pense qu'on aurait pu
même travailler c'est un instant un
moment dans le week-end ou le mercredi
ou effectivement on peut aller se
promener on peut profiter de la nature
sans avoir ce risque
premier jour dans mon département
premier jour de chasse une jeune fille
avec des plombs dans la cuisse alors oui
c'est pas d'une gravité exceptionnelle
mais on lui enlève quand même dépendant
la cuisse une voiture avec des plombs
dans sa dans sa carrosserie donc
j'entends les les accidents peuvent
baisser n'empêche que ça reste des
accidents huit accidents oui décès liés
à la chasse c'est 8 de trop et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on réfléchisse
qu'on réfléchisse à ça et le fait
d'avoir éviter
pouvoir évacuer cette question en agence
en chasse moi je suis pas bloqué et le
groupe éco-golidarité territoire n'est
absolument pas bloqué sur le fait de
dire effectivement pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'était non le week-end
et non les vacances scolaires je pense
qu'on peut trouver des alternatives moi
il me semble qu'il faut regarder aussi
dans les pays européens où on a des
alternatives qui peuvent être
intéressants mais je voudrais faire
réagir Patrick chaise est-ce que vous
avez dit vous avez employé un
qualificatif provocateur Patrick chaise
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça
bien bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci
de votre invitation ce que je pourrais
répondre à ça c'est que ce que je
constate aujourd'hui au lendemain de la
publication de ce rapport c'est que d'un
côté on a les
anti-chats qui traitent notre rapport
d'indécent quand même un mot très fort
la naissance et de l'autre côté les
chasseurs qui considèrent que en fait on
est allé à l'extrême de ce qu'on pouvait
puisque il restait plus qu'à créer un
fichier s des chasseurs
la conclusion de de constat c'est que au
fond on ne satisfait personne mais
j'allais dire on s'y était préparé mais
que finalement ça me rassure
ça me rassure parce que ce rapport est
des propos de du représentant du groupe
écologiste Daniel salmon dans la mission
il y avait une reconnaissance que le
travail avait été fait de façon
constructive avec respect est-ce qu'on
complaisance et c'est finalement ça que
je veux retenir c'est que évidemment
donc dès lors qu'on n'est pas dans un
camp on ne peut pas avoir l'adhésion du
camp mais c'était pas l'objectif que
d'être dans un camp l'objectif c'était
de répondre à la question
améliorer la sécurité à la chasse et sur
ce point là compte tenu de ces
observations je pense qu'on a atteint
cet objectif
sur le jour sans chasse je veux quand
même réagir
on va entendre Eric Douma ou peut-être
juste je fais réagir Eric Douma je vous
redonne la parole pas très chaise juste
après on va revenir dans le détail mais
largement sur ce rapport comment vous le
qualifier vous se rapporte comment vous
l'avez reçu alors moi je vais me situer
un peu entre les deux si vous voulez
entre les chasseurs et je suis chasseur
qui fulmine et disent qu'effectivement
il y a trop de réglementation et et les
écologistes alors pas vraiment Europe
Écologie Les Verts mais je dirais plutôt
les animalistes et antispécistes qui
effectivement crie au scandale parce que
on veut continuer à chasser le dimanche
et bien c'est heureux qu'on continue à
chasser le dimanche parce que si l'on
comment voulez-vous que l'on se
rencontre moi je veux plutôt prôner le
bien vivre ensemble donc si on commence
pas par ça et qu'on commence à séparer
les populations à dire vous vous avez
pas le droit d'y aller le dimanche vous
vous avez le droit c'est fini on
arrivera plus à se rencontrer donc moi
je veux pas ça je préfère plutôt qu'on
se mette autour d'une table
région par région département par
département et qu'on discute après sur
les 30 propositions
euh elles sont là moi je pense
qu'effectivement un moment donné trop de
réglementation tu la réglementation et
il faut peut-être pas raison donner la
chance à ceux qui sont sur le terrain et
donner à l'expérience qu'ils ont eux des
territoires de prendre les décisions qui
vont bien une décision dans mon
département dans le Loir-et-Cher sera
peut-être pas la même dans le Jura ou
dans ou dans la Somme donc je pense
qu'il faut plutôt se rencontrer avec les
élus locaux avec les détenteurs et que
les présidents de fédération et puis les
présidents de fédération de chasseurs
mais pas seulement les randonneurs les
vététistes les motards qu'on se rend
compte tous ensemble autour d'une table
et que l'on discute comment on peut moi
je le fais tous les dimanches
parce que par exemple la Fédération
Nationale des Chasseurs elle juge ce
rapport extrêmement choquant je cite
catalogue de mesures totalement à charge
contre la pratique de la chasse
populaire vous n'êtes pas du tout sur
cette ligne
je suis chasseur donc évidemment quand
on m'attaque sur chacun des points mais
il y a quand même il faut il faut aussi
évoluer il faut aussi réfléchir et quand
on parle de
jours sans chasse ça c'est impossible
donc évidemment mais le délit d'entrave
des litres pour moi c'est une évidence
enfin je veux dire rentrer dans une
propriété privée pour interdire des
chasseurs qui sont sur le territoire où
ils peuvent chasser aller porter
violence porter le coup de poing à ces
gens qui sont en train de faire une
opération qui est une opération de droit
je rappelle que l'achat c'est un droit
donc jusqu'à maintenant c'est un droit
porter violence et et ça va même plus
loin parfois jusqu'à détruire des
miradors qui en fait ces miradors sont
des outils de sécurité donc ça je trouve
ça très grave le délit d'entrave me va
bien je vais laisser la plante Guillaume
gantard là dessus après on reviendra pas
de trichesse promise sur le jour sans
chasse mais c'est vrai que ce délit
d'entrave aussi ça fait ça fait débat
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça
[Musique]
ça demande un petit peu plus de
d'explications mais qu'en tout cas ce
moment de respiration il est nécessaire
et moi je le dis quand j'entends les
propos de wishen je vraiment je trouve
que les chasseurs se tirent une balle
dans le pied et vous allez vous allez
vous marginaliser donc je pense que il y
a une attente mais très forte de la
société moi je suis issu d'un milieu
rural des maires d'une commune de 200
habitants je suis en lien avec les assa
etc donc j'ai pas j'ai pas de souci avec
ça je la famille qui chasse et voilà
mais il y a une attente et au milieu
rural c'est pas les urbains qui n'ont
rien compris et puis et puis les ruraux
qui qui savent tout toutes les
associations qui ont déposé et qui ont
déposé cette pétition sont issus du
milieu rural donc il y a une attente moi
je vois des mères qui me disent c'est
plus possible ce fonctionnement est donc
on doit arriver à trouver cet équilibre
je dis pas qu'il est facile je dirais
que j'aimerais pas être à la place de
Patrick chaise parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y a un équilibre difficile mais je
pense que d'avoir une proposition sur un
temps sans chasse moi ça me paraît
nécessaire on me dit que c'est pas
possible etc ça existe dans de nombreux
pays donc je pense qu'on devrait pouvoir
y arriver et en tout cas moi je pense
que c'est aussi dans l'intérêt des
chasseurs non mais quand vous dites
qu'effectivement c'est difficile d'aller
à la rencontre d'un chasseur quand il a
un fusil et que nous on est promeneur et
qu'on se promène dans la nature mais
c'est pas vrai moi tous les dimanches et
tous mes amis autour de moi rencontre
des promeneurs rencontre des vététices
rencontrent des motards il suffit
simplement d'aller à la rencontre des
chasseurs et que les chasseurs aillent à
la rencontre des promeneurs et tout se
passe bien il y a jamais aucun souci ça
fait 15 ans que je gère ça je gère deux
GIC de GS pour ceux qui savent pas c'est
des groupements d'intérêts agro silvaux
siégétique voilà bon donc et un de 5000
hectares et l'autre de 8000 hectares
donc je gère les conflits je gère les
plans de chasse je gère tout ça les
conflits en premier moi j'ai une grosse
épreuve sur un humain mais j'ai ici une
grosse épreuve de travail qui se passe
c'est une épreuve sportive de très haut
niveau mais ça se passe très bien avec
les organisateurs ils sont pas chasseurs
ils sont pourra à pied
un décès lié justement à de la Rand ben
oui mais c'est pas le temps que oui
d'accord discuter des accidents les
accidents arrivent partout les accidents
arrivent à sur la route les accidents
arrivent avec des trottinettes j'ai plus
qu'à eu d'accidents on va pas on va
passer un élément juste
justement le zéro accident et ça c'est
mais tout le monde veut y tendre mais
par contre on peut pas dire accepter les
accidents on va pas interdire les
trottinettes du monde comparaison encore
une fois avec la trottinette je pense
que on va revenir juste après Patrick
chaise on va on va donner la parole à
Patrick chasse sur ces deux points vous
le voyez qui font débat pas de jour sans
chasse et la création du délit d'entrave
oui alors effectivement vous voyez
l'image qui se passe sur votre plateau
et la démonstration ce qu'on a vécu
pendant 9 mois mais mais c'est une
démonstration qui encore une fois
apporte de l'eau ou l'un de ce rapport
qui justement a voulu être dans
l'intermédiaire c'est-à-dire qu'on est
ni prochain ni pour la chasse ce qu'on a
voulu se trouver des solutions sur le
jour s'enchasse moi je m'inscris en faut
quand on dit que on a écarté totalement
le pourcent de chasse ce qu'on a écarté
dans ce rapport c'est le jour sans
chasse uniforme sur l'ensemble du
territoire national mais ce qu'on est en
évidence et d'ailleurs ce qu'on a pu
constater et dans mon propre département
j'ignorais par exemple qu'il y a deux
jours sans chasse donc depuis très
longtemps et donc il y a un vrai
problème de communication et il y a un
vrai problème je dirais de
en fait le pourquoi tel jour où ou tel
jour quand on est en zone périurbaine
donc région parisienne par exemple dans
les forêts de maniales on ne chasse pas
le dimanche déjà et là aussi depuis très
longtemps ça veut dire que le jour
s'enchasse existe déjà et il existe donc
de façon adaptée au territoire quand on
est au fin fond de la Creuse et je
respecte bien sûr pour la Creuse alors
même qu'il y a pas de circuit de
randonnée qui a pas forcément beaucoup
de preneurs etc interdire l'achat ce
dimanche c'est absurde
par contre à l'interdire en région
parisienne comme je disais parce qu'il y
a donc un flux de promeneurs importants
mais c'est évident mais ça se fait donc
l'idée dans le rapport ça n'a pas été
dire il faut il faut pas qu'on parle
dont je ressens chasse qu'on a dit c'est
qu'il fallait que le jour sans chasse se
décide et se définissent au niveau
territorial et pour cela il fallait
mettre en place des lieux de rencontres
des lieux d'échanges pour faire en sorte
que en fonction de et bien on puisse
définir les jours sans chasse je vais
donner un exemple qui était l'image tout
à fait mon propos et qui est très
intéressant et la fédération de
Haute-Savoie la Haute-Savoie qui est un
département très touristique mais je
pourrais plus spécialiser sur d'autres
d'autres sujets qui est très en avance
aussi sur la sécurité et pour faire
plaisir à agrément tard mais aussi pour
imager mon propos donc en Haute-Savoie
en fait la réflexion se fait massive par
massif c'est à dire que en fonction des
stations de ski en fonction des circuits
de grande rodés en fonction des périodes
et bien il y a une définition deux jours
sans chasse qui se décide au niveau
local la vraie difficulté qu'on a
ensuite c'est comment on fait savoir aux
promeneurs que il faut donc il y a ça ou
pas chasse et là donc on arrive à un
autre point qui est le fait d'obliger
les chasseurs et je peux vous dire
contre leur avis contre
leur demande de donner l'information
site de chasse donc on oblige dans notre
rapport
à faire en sorte que les chasseurs
donnent donc géographiquement les
territoires sur lesquels ils chassent
quand on a une réponse juste Patrick
chaise une réponse rapide de Guillaume
après on va passer à la question de la
formation Patrick chaise est assez et ça
c'est évident enfin je lui remercie
parce qu'en fait il explique que
féculent ça existe déjà ça existe déjà
dans les forêts domaniale où
effectivement chasse pas le dimanche
donc ça ne pose pas de problématique
particulière quand il dit que ça existe
dans son département effectivement mais
c'est peut-être pas le week-end et donc
c'est en période où voilà tout le monde
n'est pas forcément
les deux jours Patrick chaise les deux
jours sans chasse dans votre département
voilà c'est ça et donc ça veut dire
juste que c'est possible moi je fais une
proposition très simple moi je suis tout
à fait d'accord pour territorialiser
parce que en fonction des départements
en fonction des types de chasse on n'a
pas on n'a pas les mêmes les mêmes
problématiques il y a une proposition
très simple c'est de dire c'est
d'inverser les choses c'est de dire on a
le droit à trois quatre jours de chasse
par semaine avec une obligation d'avoir
une le dimanche après-midi ou samedi
après-midi ça s'apaise discuter dans
lequel il n'y a pas de chasse et que ça
s'assoit à l'échelle nationale et que ça
soit connue par tout le monde moi il me
semble et j'en fais le pari ici je suis
certain qu'à un moment ou un autre on
arrivera à ça parce qu'il y a une
demande tellement forte et que et que
encore une fois moi j'en appelle au
chasseur travailler sur cette question
là parce que c'est une demande et que on
y arrivera mais vaut mieux que ça se
fasse justement de manière partagée et
allons dans cette direction moi vraiment
la réponse à la formation mais allez-y
répondait pourquoi c'est pas possible
bon c'est pas possible parce qu'on peut
pas commencer par interdire là l'idée
c'est quand même on commence par
interdire donc non on se met autour
d'une table je viens de dire oui mais
justement derrière c'est tout de suite
l'interdiction qui vient et donc moi je
veux pas de ça moi j'ai des gens qui
travaillent la ils n'ont que le dimanche
pour pratiquer la chasse il faut il faut
le faire la chasse il faut aussi quand
on a des besoins de régulation il y a
des dates et on a des décrets et on a
des arrêtés préfectoraux qui vous
donnent des dates et on est obligé de le
faire je rappelle aussi parce qu'on
parlait des forêt domaniales juste que
80% des territoires le territoire privé
quand même donc faut quand même le
rappeler au minimum on va parler de la
question de la formation c'est aussi
l'un des points du rapport et Audrey
vous nous emmener dans le Morbihan à
Saint-Jean-Brévelay très précisément ou
des chasseurs apprennent à être
responsable de battus les enjeux sont
importants en cas d'accident leur
responsabilité est engagée en garde
votre reportage
et après voilà ça va être par rapport au
Mirador mais surtout les zones à
protéger des directions vers lesquelles
il sera formellement interdit de viser
ou de manipuler une arme un chemin un
bâtiment ou un autre chasseur évidemment
pour le protéger je vais faire 5 pas
vers ce danger donc là c'est le chemin
le bout du chemin donc on fait 5 pas
et trois pas perpendiculaires
c'est l'axe des 32 degrés 40% des
accidents pourraient être évités en
tenant compte de cette règle mais dans
l'action certains chasseurs ont tendance
à l'oublier il y a des gens ils veulent
pas entendre parler de ça parce que il y
a quand on parle du sanglier c'est fini
ils sont fous
les piquets sont là mais de s'ennuyer
passent tant pis c'est justement pour
éviter cela que ces chasseurs suivent
une formation facultatif pour l'instant
afin d'être chef de ligne ou responsable
de battus ce seront bientôt eux qui
devront placer les tireurs et surtout
faire respecter les règles
si jamais il y a un accident c'est le
responsable de ligne et le chef de battu
qui peuvent être engagés au pénal après
la pratique la théorie retour sur les
bancs de l’école avec d'autres règles de
sécurité si vous avez des invités
précisez que derrière la haie il y a une
route il y a un chemin derrière le bois
il y a une maison à rappeler à chaque
début de battu c'est quand même
important on a une heure de les mains on
peut tuer donc il faut en être
conscience et tout les jeunes chasseurs
sont déjà plus au courant parce que ça
fait pas longtemps qu'ils ont passé leur
permis et on va essayer de remettre son
application pour les plus anciens qui
eux ont pris des pas forcément les
bonnes habitudes le thème sécurité on le
retrouve en permanence en permanence
dans toutes nos réunions donc toutes nos
formations c'est l'image de la chasse
qui en passe et qui passe par là et qui
redorent l'image de la chasse quand ils
font ces formations là l'information va
même jusqu'au gestes de premier secours
dispensés par les pompiers je viens
bloquer le coude ici pour pas que ça
tête et sa main ne bouge dans ce que sa
tête car la chasse se pratique souvent
en milieu isolé les premiers gestes sont
primordiaux on espère que ça va diffuser
partout et que quand on nous en arrive
et bien il y a des gestes qui ont déjà
été
faits cette formation facultative vient
compléter le permis de chasse délivré
après un examen théorique et pratique
depuis les années 2000 à cela s'ajoute
depuis 2019 l'obligation pour tous les
chasseurs de suivre une formation
décennale trois heures de retour sur les
règles de sécurité
ses chasseurs il n'y aurait pas besoin
d'en faire plus faire plus actuellement
non c'est quelque chose qui qui est très
récent donc il faut aussi laisser le
temps au chasseur de se former et là
c'est lancé nous nous avons plus de 2000
personnes de former actuellement sur les
10000 chasseurs morbihaniés l'an dernier
90 accidents de chasse ont été recensés
en France
Audrey cette formation elle est
facultatives à l'heure actuelle le
rapport la préconise de la rendre
obligatoire c'est indispensable pour
vous ça me paraît indispensable et moi
quand j'ai lu ce rapport et je pensais
aux gens de l'extérieur qui connaissent
pas trop et qui se rapportent quand même
que on a un vrai décalage quoi je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de mesures de
sécurité qui sont de bon sens et
auxquelles je pensais qu'elles étaient
déjà appliquées sur la question par
exemple bon bah de l'alcool ça me
paraissait une évidence en fait quand on
a une arme qui est une arme létale enfin
qui permet de tuer je pense qu'il faut
voilà avoir des mesures de sécurité très
strictes donc pour le coup tout cet
encadrement va dans le bon sens mais je
pense qu'on a pris un retard
considérable et qu'effectivement il faut
être beaucoup plus beaucoup plus clair
sur ces mesures de sécurité les
appliquer le fait qu'il y a une
formation donc ça je crois que c'est
prévu d'avoir un retour tous les tous
les 10 ans je pense que c'est un peu
long on pourrait faire au moins tous les
tous les 5 ans parce que je pense que
d'avoir un retour d'avoir une formation
de de revenir sur des éléments
essentiels ça me paraît ça me paraît ça
me paraît important après je pense que
sur la question des mineurs aussi je
pense qu'il y a aussi une question
morale avoir un fusil avoir une arme qui
peut tuer ce n'est pas anodin ce n'est
pas rien
mineur ça me paraît ça me paraît aussi
une évidence bon la réponse j'ai
l'impression de vivre dans un autre
monde mais ceci étant je veux revenir
sur la formation décennale elle est
obligatoire à l'époque facultative donc
elle est obligatoirement
est obligatoire donc ça veut dire que
déjà on forme tout le monde et on va
obliger tout le monde à se former sur la
sécurité donc ça c'est important oui sur
les chefs de battus moi pourquoi pas
absolument j'y suis pas opposé du tout
je l'ai même passé moi donc il y a pas
de souci donc ça c'est c'est une
évidence et pourquoi j'ai l'impression
d'être dans dans un autre monde mais
mais nous dans nos chasse on a les
enfants qui nous accompagnent ils sont
heureux d'aller ramasser le lièvre du
grand-père qui a qui a été tué et de le
donner à son grand-père qui va préparer
à Patel lièvre après enfin je veux dire
c'est ils vivent avec nous
on n'est pas dans un monde de bisounours
où on protège les gens moi les enfants
et je me souviens effectivement c'était
peut-être un peu avant mais on pouvait
aller à la chasse on pouvait voir la
grand-mère en train de tuer le lapin
c'est pas c'est pas des raisonnable le
la mort ça fait partie de la vie c'est
faut juste pas l'oublier ça et moi les
enfants ils ont juste ils ont juste une
évidence et que ils savent ils
accompagnent la chasse ils sont heureux
d'être avec leurs parents avec leurs
grands-parents et participer à cette
journée de fête c'est une fête la chasse
et la conclusion
qui est un peu différent la conclusion
pour Patrick chaise sur ce rapport il
tout de suite de ce rapport qu'elles
vont à l'être
alors les conclusions encore une fois
c'est que globalement je remercie
Guillaume de
d'avouer que il y a des certaines
mesures qui sont proposées qui sont qui
vont dans le bon sens comme donc il
parlait de des jeux notamment on propose
le tutorat on me propose des choses
comme ça qui vont dans le sens un petit
peu de l'accompagnement de la formation
etc donc très franchement je peux dire
c'est que le travail il a été fait
en profondeur avec sérieux et avec cet
objectif encore une fois de tenter la
réconciliation on voit que c'est
compliqué mais j'ose espérer que on ira
dans le bon sens quand tout le monde
aura un peu lu en détail parce que là il
y a eu des réactions très vives et très
rapide sans à mon sens avoir compris la
finalité de certaines de ces
dispositions alors aujourd'hui
oui aujourd'hui on va écouter donc ces
retours on va analyser donc ces
critiques et puis l'objectif c'est pour
demain donc de une proposition de loi
tout n'est pas donc du domaine de la loi
il y a des mesures qui seront
réglementaires en espérant que et les
chasseurs et les longs chasseurs
s'inspirent déjà des propositions qu'on
a faite et ce sera la conclusion merci
beaucoup
[Musique]